Time and time again, Netflix has proven itself
to be the perfect place for audiences to discover
overlooked movies, and for those overlooked
movies to finally get some eyes on them.
Perhaps it's due to the wider audience or
the ease of browsing for new flicks to watch,
but either way, a lot of box office flops
and critical bombs have Netflix to thank for their viewership.
One of those flops is the 2020 sci-fi action
movie Skylines, currently dominating Netflix's viewership charts.
The dystopian adventure is actually the third
entry in the Skyline franchise, following
2010's Skyline and 2017's Beyond Skyline.
Sadly, the trilogy got started on a less-than-ideal
note, with the 2010 original tanking at the
box office and receiving mostly poor reviews
from critics.
However, Beyond Skyline rejected the sophomore
slump expectation and wound up earning pretty
solid reviews, even if audiences still weren't
totally on board with the franchise.
"Things are looking up, kid."
Skylines debuted in theaters and on Apple
TV in December 2020, but its arrival on Netflix
in March 2021 has breathed new life into the
movie.
As of March 23, Skylines has remained in the
list of Netflix's top ten most-watched movies
in the U.S. for several days - something not
many other projects, film or otherwise, have achieved.
Directed by Liam O'Donnell, who also wrote
the film's script, Skylines picks up where
the second film left off: now-grown-up resistance
leader Captain Rose Corley is leading a team
of elite mercenaries, including both humans
and bio-mechanical entities that were formerly
enslaved as soldiers.
The end of Beyond Skylines saw Rose and her
team flying around the Moon, attacking other ships.
At the start of Skylines, the human portion
of the crew is focused on battling the Harvester
mothership known as the Armada, which will
use its weapons to blow up Earth.
Rose hits a crossroads when she realizes that
the only way she can defeat the Armada and
save Earth is to put one of her own ships
in the line of fire, a move that could only
result in everyone on the ship dying.
She makes the difficult decision in order
to protect Earth, then disappears for half
a decade as she works through her guilt and
grief.
When Rose emerges, living in London amongst
Pilot aliens and trying to keep herself hidden
from Leon, humanity has changed.
A virus breaks out and turns into a pandemic,
affecting Pilots and anyone who has Pilot parts.
It destroys not only the Pilots' bodies but
also their minds, causing them to revert back
to their original hostile selves.
"The pilots are dying, Rose.
What you saw today was only the beginning."
It's up to Rose and her team to put an end
to the virus before it's too late.
The group heads to the aliens' home planet
in an attempt to save the world.
At the time of its release, Skylines didn't
blow people away - not critics and not general audiences.
Some reviews were mostly negative and some
were rather glowing, but across the board,
critics felt that Skylines was kind of like
its title: a middle-of-the-road movie that
rests on the horizon line.
Polygon's Tasha Robinson put it best when
she wrote in her review of the film,
"Skylines feels like the respectable thirtysomething
iteration of a familiar friend who used to
be a rowdy teen, then a reckless and wild
twentysomething.
It's perfectly passable low-key science fiction,
almost certainly destined for a fast trip
to Netflix, where it can be taken up as an
amiable evening's viewing."
Netflix is exactly where Skylines ended up,
and subscribers are now singing the film's praises.
One Twitter user wrote,
"Skylines is honestly a good movie and I hope
y'all will watch it now that it's on Netflix
because it's soooo worth it and that it's
what the cast & crew deserve!!"
Critic Matthew Essary even took the time to
share a six-tweet thread about Skylines' merits, writing in part,
"I wanted to let you know that the incredibly
fun sci-fi sequel SKYLINES is on @netflix
starting today [March 18, 2021]!
It joins the previous entry in the series,
BEYOND SKYLINE, on the services and these
two films form an excellent standalone sci-fi
tale.
[...] I legitimately love SKYLINES and the
earlier BEYOND SKYLINE and I think you will too."
If you're in the mood for a fun, action-packed
adventure, Skylines is worth adding to your must-watch list.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.